je me fais invisible c'est ça le plan
tout le monde est après moi je te dirai
pas où tu es
lequel d'entre vous vous en arreter de
moi s'il vous plaît
tu es en état d'arrestation
alors théodore pourquoi s'il veut te
faire enfermer dans une cellule tout le
monde le sait la mutuelle
[Musique]
il nous a presque tué
qu'est ce que tu as fait j'ai fait ce
que j'avais à faire
pour te retrouver teddy
légendaire bob vidic tient chico pat
tu es professionnel
la fesci les mauvaises personnes et je
vais tuer
lâche cette arme personne tue personne
ici
au
jeu devrait savoir ce qui te passe par
la tête à ce moment
où
voilà
observé
est-ce que c'est grave qu'est ce qui
titille ôté dit honteux nelhomme je
réponds plus amicales et moins formels
tony et cette sortie ne touche pas à mon
contrat je peux passer un contrat
concurrence c'est-à-dire que plusieurs
personnes veillent à un certain théodore
moi tout est bob est ce qu'on va devoir
se battre en duel
fais moi sortir d'ici
c'est toujours et seulement important de
tenir
et
[Musique]
voilà
faisons un marché j'ai beaucoup de
pognon n'y a pas de marché à faire à
l'otv
tu connais les règles
je dois tout savoir on aurait dû me
laisser lui mettre une balle dans la
tête quand j'en avais la chance
[Musique]
sais tu en as besoin ted hybride
je n'est entré que tu le veuilles ou non
à
tu vois la différence ça c'est un
psychopathe war